NBA free agency we talked about it a
little bit in the first hour the program
we had a news update from Adrian woods
in the rouse key that Kevin Durant has
declined his thirty one and a half
million dollar option with the Golden
State Warriors and laid out some of the
parameters and options for KD he's a
busy man we do appreciate his time
everybody who covers the NBA especially
somebody here in Los Angeles who covers
the Los Angeles Lakers not like it's
never it's never a slow day in Bill
worm's world bill Orem with the athletic
he's covered the Lakers since 2013 he
covers them on a day-in day-out basis
the content never slows down and we
thank you for taking a couple of minutes
to join us here on the Rich Eisen show
thank you very much thanks for having me
well appreciate it what is your weekend
looking like as you get set to think
about everything to come on Sunday I
mean every NBA reporter I'm sure has
told family okay I'm probably gonna be
locked up pretty tight here over the
next few days and this is pretty much
your existing I mean you think so but my
wife life doesn't stop my wife scheduled
family photos for Sunday mornings I'm
gonna go from like family photos like
cheese to to all of a sudden like
fighting about what happens at 3 p.m.
and checking my phone non-stop probably
but I mean this is this is a really
obviously for obvious reasons evalee
anticipated for agent period for the
lakers and this has happened every
summer going back to 2013 when dwight
howard was a free agent almost every
summer they have found a way to create
cap space and chase whoever the biggest
guys on the market are and they've been
constantly rejected up until last summer
when they got LeBron James but you know
we've heard kind of this idea that
LeBron players don't necessarily want to
come be LeBrons number two well the
Lakers took that off the board they went
and got LeBrons number two so now the
question is can you lure one of those
top guys to be LeBrons number three that
the three musketeers here and try to
restore something to the Lakers who have
been you know really a real black mark
on the legacy of this franchise over the
last six years so bill if we're thinking
about what's to come on Sunday and
what's to come thereafter already the
biggest move thus far has been the
addition of Anthony Davis and the trade
consummated and we can get into some of
the particulars there because even that
came with a little level of intrigue and
controversy but are we talking about a
summer here that is part of a plan a
multi-year plan because this was one of
the great talking points out of the
Lakers organization
specifically from magic who did a lot of
the talking and who still does a lot of
the talking but you know magic had made
it seem like well we never said we were
gonna get two in one off season we got
LeBron and now it's up to us to get one
here in the summer of 2019 how much of
what's to come here is sort of flying by
the seat of their pants and how much of
this is an overarching plan from the
Lakers organization well the first step
was obviously getting LeBron James and
and once once they once the Paul George
thing happened last year were Paul
George before free agency even began
reuptake emitted to Russell Westbrook
and the Thunder they almost had to make
it a multi-year plan because there
wasn't a scenario where they could they
where they could build a championship
team around LeBron last year without
without really tying themselves up and
killing their flexibility so they tried
to they tried to kind of split the baby
a little bit with we're gonna get some
veterans when we're gonna get my minimum
deals that's how you end up with you
know
JaVale McGee Lance Stephenson Rondo
Michael Beasley who was a you know who
did not contribute at all
now the multi-year flexibility is is
gone you know they they basically wasted
a year of LeBrons career you have him at
35 going into 30 age 35 year this has to
be an all-in summer there is no well if
we don't get a guy in this summer we'll
push that cap space into 2020 they have
they know they have LeBron James and
Anthony Davis together for one year
Anthony Davis is a free agent next
summer now all expectations are that he
is going to return that this is going to
be a long-term marriage between Anthony
Davis and the Lakers this is where he
wanted to be but we've seen this before
we saw it with Dwight Howard we've seen
how things can go sideways and we don't
know what the Lakers you know look like
in this new Rob pálinka running the show
era with it with a potentially
diminishing LeBron James
so the Lakers need a lot of things to go
right this year so they can feel
comfortable that they're going to have
Anthony Davis into the future so this
summer is is the ultimate test for the
organization but they absolutely have to
emerge from this summer as as title
contenders to make good on the trade
they made for Anthony Davis because they
mortgage their entire future with the
pieces and the assets they sent to New
Orleans so Magic Johnson very famously
and you were there Staples Center when
he resigned his position
unbeknownst to a lot of the power
brokers in Los Angeles
what changes from last summer to this
summer with magic out well I mean
frankly you lose you lose that closer I
mean there were a lot of things that
magic brought to the table that maybe
weren't positive in terms of you know
hubris or a lack of accountability or
just being in the office I mean
something we've heard a lot about him
but one thing you can't argue is that in
terms of charisma and and being able to
kind of sell the Lakers dream nobody was
ever better at that than Magic Johnson
and so him not being in the picture
presumably I cannot imagine that he will
be involved in any in any in any
recruiting he's out there he's she's
trying but you lose kind of that person
who can really kind of sell the mystique
of the Lakers now the Lakers to some
degree sell themselves and you have you
have Jeanie buss who is a great
ambassador for the Lakers as well but I
think what the Lakers are trying to sell
this summer is is stability and
credibility that you know the wild card
of magic is is no longer here you have
Rob palinka who you know is a a savvy
former agent would be that would be
their pitch you have Kurt Rambis who has
four decades of experience in the NBA
and you have a great tradition come be a
part of it but we don't know how free
agents look at the Lakers we just LeBron
is the only guy over the last six years
who who said yes to this and he came
when it was a completely blank slate and
they have changed almost everything
since he got here to fit more his
timeline to fit to reflect his where he
is in his career and that you know is a
big a big adjustment for the Lakers and
so does a guy like Kemba Walker want to
be a part of that does Jimmy Butler want
to be a part of that we just don't know
yet and that's and that's what I think
the most interesting thing about this
free agency period is how appealing are
the Lakers now they all have this
two-headed monster we are speaking with
Bill arm of the athletic you covers the
Los Angeles Lakers has done so since
2013 you can file a bill on twitter at
bill or mon Darren Smith this is the
Rich Eisen show do the Lakers want
magics help at this point you know you
you wrote a column where he spoke with
you and he talked a little bit about
DeAngelo Russell potentially returning
how much more mature he is how much
better he is also the simple fact that
none of the players who were in the
locker room but D'Angelo first go around
are still there which I thought was an
interesting detail because we always
suspected that what went on with him and
Nick Young was factored in but we never
I never at least saw it in black and
white if you're the Lakers in your Genie
bus and you're Rob polenka he's Magic
Johnson but do you want him out there
campaigning and politicking on the
Lakers behalf I don't think so I'm
because it it adds to this idea that
there's a dysfunction with the Lakers
because magic was calling the shots but
now he's not calling the shots be still
out there saying what the Lakers should
do it leads to questions about who's in
charge in LA there's already that
question is it is it Kurt Rambis is it
is it Jeanie buss is it Rob pálinka but
if you still have magic you know in the
peanut gallery it just it just adds to
this confusion around the organization I
think you want to be lockstep everybody
rowing in the same direction one vision
and magic might very well be you know
sharing company secrets here with the
DeAngelo Russell plan or some of the
other free agents he mentioned to me but
if you thought Lakers you don't want him
to be the person who is putting a face
on the direction of the franchise he he
he gave back that baton he passed on the
opportunity to be that person for the
organization
if I were Jeanie buss I'd say here's
here's a hundred thousand bucks get on a
cruise for a couple of weeks you know
let this window a free agency open up
magic do us all a favor
you know log off Twitter for a little
while I mean again and I feel it feels
weird saying that because I go away four
hundred thousand bucks plus a lot of us
would I don't know the magic would
though I mean magic magic turned down
this this opportunity just so he could
return to being Magic Johnson and his
words but I keep thinking to myself you
know he's Magic Johnson he's one of the
most important maybe the most important
player in franchise history yet if
you're genie bus and Rob polenka you
have to you have to cringe when you know
that he's set up to do an interview or
that he's speaking to bill Orem of the
athletic because you just don't know
what he's gonna say and how it's gonna
be interpreted especially after he went
pretty hard after rob blink and some of
the stuff he said I mean it just I'd say
hey magic here's an all-expense-paid
cruise go to Europe for a couple of
weeks come back let us figure this out I
mean he's going to do that that is his
annual summer routine is is sailing
around the Mediterranean
coast of Italy so he will be he will be
there I don't think Jeanne needs to pay
for it but you but you're right I mean
obviously he is he is the
unpredictability was always one of one
of the issues with magic you go back to
last summer entering the free agency
period they they had their draft and he
steps up and says you know we're gonna
get this done well why because I'm Magic
Johnson how are you going to do it no
answers but then he says if I don't do
it if I don't get a superstar in here I
will resign and it's it's that sort of
braggadocio or whatever you want to call
it that I think made people question
whether the Lakers were truly stable and
doing things the right way and for the
right reason and so if you if you kind
of remove that that mindset that
mentality that behavior you do have the
opportunity to shape yourself as a more
credible organization which is obviously
something the Lakers are trying to do
and we saw this even last week the
Lakers were granted permission to speak
to Ron Adams the assistant in Golden
State now okay how important are
assistant coaches that really as
important as a max free agent I mean of
course not but the Lakers have spent so
much time hiring out of their own past
or Genie bus you know leaning so closely
on her you know closest friends it was
actually encouraging to see them make a
move to try to go get somebody who is
widely regarded as the most respected
assistant in the NBA they probably
aren't gonna get him but to at least
make that effort is a really encouraging
sign from about the way they're thinking
now I don't know if that would have
happened when magic was still here so
what's realistic for the Lakers and and
we all see these free agent lists top
five top tens what in your opinion is
realistic based on their salary
constraints based on their needs
what would you view from a scale of
Kawhi Leonard Kevin Durant at the top of
the pier what would you view is
realistic for the Lakers heading in a
free agency I mean I think I think you
know Kevin Durant absolutely not Kawhi
Leonard 2% chance I mean that's your
dream and at that point but Kyrie seems
to be going elsewhere but once you get
beyond those guys
everything seems to be in play whether
it's you know Kemba Walker if if he
decide if he doesn't get the money he
likes from from Charlotte he's gonna be
up he's gonna be looking around and
there are options obviously whether it's
New York Boston but then there's the
Lakers and
Kemba Walker is a bonafide all-star
point guard an elite score and and true
could truly be that third star next to
LeBron and Anthony Davis now if you
don't get that max to your guy though
that's when you get into the DeAngelo
Russell zone and DeAngelo Russell
probably makes the most sense of those
guys who are in that 23 to 26 million
dollar range because that's where you
have Nikolov Vukovich and Malcolm
Brogdon DeAngelo Russell is the guy who
really feels like he could be on the
move and there's a lot of irony to that
obviously I mean I'm Magic Johnson
shipped him out of town
basically to basically send him to
Brooklyn that's finishing school to
potentially come back to the Lakers but
he has been he became an all-star in
Brooklyn when I talked to Magic about
this two nights ago outside the NBA
Awards
he said he's more mature he is a he has
become the leader that magic questioned
that he could be two years ago that
makes a lot of sense
he's affordable but he's not such a big
star that you worry that he's not going
that he's going to detract from what
LeBron and ad have going on and he also
saves you a few dollars to spend in free
agency so all of that like kind of paves
the way I think to a potential DeAngelo
Russell reunion but of course that is
predicated on the Nets having the summer
they want and getting Kyrie Irving and
potentially Kevin Durant also but it's
that's why all these pieces all affect
everything else it's a significant set
of dominoes that you have to think
you're gonna start following pretty
early on Sunday so of the 24 or 28
depending on on whether or not Anthony
Davis uses the trade we're here 24 28
usually about the the amount of money
that you see attached with the Lakers
and free agency your opinion your
analysis do you think they're better off
spending that the majority of that on an
individual or filling in a bunch of
different pieces here maybe getting two
different three different players for
that sum or does it depend on who we're
talking about player wise well I think I
think I think it's I think that it's
it's who it is and you know either one
of those could be successful I think the
problem is we've only seen Rob palinka
put together a roster once and it was
last summer when he ended up with Lance
Stephenson rajon rondo
JaVale McGee and that just didn't work
and so there is this great unknown of
did he learn a less
there does he have a better sense of how
to build a roster around LeBron how to
get the right pieces in place if you're
saying great here's twenty eight million
dollars go split it up and he doesn't
put the right guys well then what was
what what good was it
and I happen to be in the camp that if
you have that if you have that max slot
use it on the one guy get the best
possible player you can if you can get
Kemba Walker
Jimmy Butler DeAngelo Russell you do it
because then you at least secure you
have insurance against LeBron in decline
whether it's his age or injury we've saw
him having the most significant injury
of his career last season if you have
Jimmy Butler and Anthony Anthony Davis
and LeBron is you know for whatever
reason misses 30 40 games
I believe that duo still get you to the
playoffs and you need that again going
back to my earlier point you need this
team to be as good as it possibly can be
this year you need to make as deep of a
run as it can to compel Anthony Davis to
stay and you don't want to be in a
situation where you have surrounded
Anthony Davis with a bunch of nice role
players but LeBron is not able to
contribute at the level that you are
anticipating right now they missed the
playoffs LeBron is getting older
Anthony Davis doesn't have much faith
and in Rob palinka or the Lakers starts
taking meetings next July you just
cannot risk that you have to do
everything you can to lock him in right
now and that is by making building a
championship team and you do that with
stars ohne buzz Rob polenka even to one
of your previous columns LeBron James
there's there's enough pressure to be
spread around here in this organization
we're gonna have a lot of eyeballs and
expectations from layer to layer to
layer inside of this organization from
top to management to player right I mean
because we all had associated LeBron
with part of management when we saw that
famous shot of him and pálinka and magic
when LeBron wasn't playing a game so
you're the three different layers just
trying to think about how involved is
Magic in any of this or excuse me how
involved is LeBron in any other they
don't do any of this without LeBron
James right you don't trade to former
number two overall picks and number four
overall pick two future firsts and Josh
Hart for Anthony Davis if that is your
starting point you you do it because you
have LeBron James and you don't have any
more time to waste like you you've you
can't mess around any longer and so
whether it's LeBron pulling the strings
or not they certainly are honoring his
presence but
with the move for ad and you have to do
that further with with with the rest of
the roster construction because if if
you somehow don't maximize this window
with LeBron and you've traded those
picks you've traded that young core it
will go down as an all-time disaster in
the history of this organization and in
the NBA and you can you just after the
last six years they've had the detour
they've taken from the top of the NBA
they can't afford they can't afford to
continue that last thing quickly is just
a clipper factor here because yeah I
know you and I have talked enough over
the years that yeah there's always this
dismissive attitude from Laker fans
towards clipper fans and and I don't
deny that it still exists today but do
the Lakers they're still the Lakers are
they paying attention to what happens
it's been a lot of chatter over the last
couple of months about while you have
the stable franchise you have this role
reversal the stable franchise in the
Clippers with Ballmer and the logo and
Doc Rivers and then you have this chaos
over here and if you want to play in Los
Angeles maybe it's time to rethink that
are they paying attention to what's
going on or are they similar to their
fans in that there is this dismissive
attitude even to this day from the
Lakers towards the Clippers
it's a little bit of both I think I
think there is still that Lakers hubris
you know why do the Clippers get so much
praise when they haven't won anything
yet well and I think the answer is
because you can see them you can see
them building you see them trending in
the right direction the fact that they
haven't been afraid to be bold and and
you know trade their best players to
create opportunities and bring back
assets and you know build frankly the
right way and and I think there is
concern about market share and and the
Clippers taking advantage of the Lakers
being you know outside of the playoffs
and obviously you had you had the LOB
city era which did which failed to
really take off to the level that they
obviously aspired but if if the Clippers
are able to get let's say Kawhi Leonard
and you know Kevin Durant thought to be
still in the mix there if they're able
to really have the summer they want to
have and the Lakers don't put that third
star around 80 and LeBron James
it's not gonna become a clipper town
it's never going to become a secret on
this just to we're generations away from
that there's just too much history but
it you could have the situation where
you have the best team in the NBA in LA
and it's not the Lakers and that is
something that in my opinion the Lakers
are terrified of we saw Genie buses
emails in some great reporting from the
LA Times earlier this year where she was
very dismissive of Steve Ballmer and his
aspirations of you know building you
know a clipper specific arena and really
kind of expanding their footprint in Los
Angeles referring to him as balls so I
think that there is a real fear within
the Lakers of of the Clippers kind of
coming for their town hey good luck this
weekend I mean I'm just having this
image of you middle of family photos
kids wives everything happening and hey
sorry I guess there's gonna be like one
photo on my wall like blown up to like
like real life size like everybody's
smiling and me looking at my phone or
tweeting that'll be the family photo for
bill or bill we appreciate any Laker fan
who's out there wants to follow bills
outstanding work do so at the athletic
you could do it at Bill Orem on Twitter
and we thank you thanks for stopping by
today thank you in person by the way
after all those years of speaking on the
telephone absolutely appreciate that
thank you very much for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app